قال المنسق الرئاسي الامريكيه الخاصه عام
66 الاتفاق الاخير لترسيم الحدود البحريه
بين لبنان واسرائيل لا يحل جميع النزاعات
بين البلدين ولا ينهي التوترات بين حزب
الله والاسرائيليين وابدا في مقابله مع
الجزيره ثقته باستمرار الحكومه
الاسرائيليه في الانتصار
للالاتفاق الذي قال انه يصب في مصلحه
الطرفين
حدود بحرينيه
لانها لم تخلقه كما ان حزب الله قال انه
سيدعم الحكومه اللبنانيه كجهه سياديه تتخذ
هذه القرارات الاتفاق لم يكن بريا ولا يحل
كل النزاعات بين البلدين ولا ينهي
التوترات بين حزب الله والجيش الاسرائيلي
هذه المشاكل قائمه وعلينا ان لا نتظاهر
انه يحلها لك انه يحل جزءا كبيرا من هذه
الخلافات في المياه ويسمح للشركات
العالميه لاول مره بالاستثمار في تلك
المنطقه على الجانب اللبناني